so in the last video Sal and I were
talking about the Civil War Battle of
Antietam and Antietam took place in
Maryland on September 17th 1862 and just
to briefly recap Antietam was the single
bloodiest day in American history over
4,000 people died and Antietam was a
signature victory in the Civil War for
the north for Abraham Lincoln and the
forces of the United States and one
thing that was really important about
Antietam was that Lincoln had been
waiting for a Union victory so that he
could proclaim the Emancipation
Proclamation which was intended to be a
real morale blow to the south and also a
signal to both enslaved people in the
south northern Republicans who were
strongly in favor of abolition the end
of slavery and also the world's
especially Europe that the Civil War had
become a fight to end slavery not just a
fight to keep the Union together and I
mentioned in the last video that there
were two reasons why Antietam was so
important the first being that it led to
the Emancipation Proclamation the second
reason was slightly related to that the
eyes of the world were really on the
United States and on the Civil War at
this time and many people in Europe were
trying to decide whether they should
intervene in the American Civil War now
why would they do this well I think the
most important reason that they would do
this is because the south of the United
States supplied 75% of the world's
cotton at the beginning of the Civil War
and so two major industrialized nations
especially the United Kingdom cotton was
the source of their prosperity they
based their economy in part around
textile mills this was what England was
known for during the Civil War the North
blockaded the South which meant that
they use the ships of the Navy to
prevent supplies from getting in or
crops from getting out of the American
South so if England can't get their
cotton crops they might be in a whole
lot of trouble when it comes to textile
manufacturing and in fact the
Confederacy was counting on having the
support of Europe in their rebellion
against the United States partly for
this reason now there were other reasons
why Europe might have intervened on
behalf of the south one of these was
that Europe was traditionally a highly
clasped Society and they had a lot of
sympathy for the way that the south did
things with a wealthy planter class
similar to the monarchy or the gentry in
Europe which was in control of poorer
White's and enslaved people of African
descent another reason was that it was
to the advantage of Europe not to have
such a strong nation as the United
States operating in the Americas
remember that this is the era of
imperialism the very beginning of
imperialism as countries like the United
Kingdom and France Germany and others in
Europe begin to look for colonies abroad
and the United States had in 1820
proclaimed the Monroe Doctrine which
said Europe keep out of the Americas we
consider this our area of the world so
dividing what had been the United States
into two smaller nations would probably
have worked out in their favor
so Europe had these social or cultural
reasons to join with the south and also
political or perhaps foreign policy
reasons to join with the south now the
salad was really counting on the
intervention of a European nation they
thought certainly the United Kingdom
would intercede on their behalf and it
looked especially early in the civil war
like that might be the case
but when it came down to it the United
Kingdom did not intercede for the south
and there were a few reasons why that
happened
one of those reasons was that the South
had kind of oversold cotton to England
in the years leading up to the Civil War
so there was actually a considerable
supply on hand which English merchants
had built up before the Civil War kind
of seeing this coming so the loss of new
southern cotton really didn't turn out
to be as big of a problem as many had
imagined and related to that as the
Civil War began to ramp up both Egypt
and India which were also cotton
producers began to increase their
production understanding that there
would be more of a demand coming from
England that couldn't be supplied from
the American South so it's interesting
to note that it's partly in response to
the American Civil War and the northern
blockade of southern ships that Egypt in
India become the world suppliers of
cotton that they will be for the rest of
the 19th century the other reason that
England doesn't aid the South is more of
a cultural reason which I think is very
interesting which is that the novel
Uncle Tom's Cabin which we'll talk about
more in other videos was read really
widely in England it was a very popular
novel there the stage shows of Uncle
Tom's Cabin were quite common and this
novel which in the United States had
helped to propel the Civil War by
showing northerners how barbaric and
institution slavery was also came over
to England and because the Battle of
Antietam allowed Lincoln to make the
Emancipation Proclamation to the
citizens of England this meant now that
the North was an army of liberation that
they had the choice of siding with
either southern slaveholders who had
been demonized in Uncle Tom's Cabin or
with northerners who were fighting
against those slaveholders so because of
the Emancipation Proclamation and
because of these other side issues about
the supply of cotton Antietam really
marks the moment when it becomes clear
that there is not going to be any
European help for the south
and that's really important because
think of the American movement for
independence the reason that the United
States won are at least one reason that
the United States won was because of the
intervention of France the South knew
that they needed the help of Europe if
they were going to succeed had England
interceded it's highly likely that the
South may have won the American Civil
War and it would have been a separate
nation after the Battle of Antietam and
the Emancipation Proclamation it became
clear that if the South was going to win
its independence from the north it would
be doing it on its own